hallo ich hätte gerne meine frau erst
mal ausgeschrieben
ein geschirrhandtuch treutel bitte
tschuldigung diese variante kassenzettel
von ikea
habe es gleich
ich hätte gern 500 gramm rindfleisch
bitte tschuldigung zu jung kleinen
moment bitte ich habe eine
plastikschüssel dabei muss ja nicht sein
mit dem ganzen verpackungsmüll gilt
freilich recht hans also nochmal 500
kinder hackfleisch vom schwein
es war ein scherz
dann hätte ich gern doch ach ja bitte
zwei scheiben von dem weiß
was in die plastikschüssel jaja haben
sich ruhig bleiben morgen kommt
ja und das ist corny was ist und das ist
sie sauer und pasta na das ist ja
paprika tiflis ja dann bitte nur einen
löffel weil ich mag das wenn gar nicht
aber meine frau glaube ich mag das tun
sie es einfach drauf
sonst da war's jahre bitte noch zwei
löffel vom sauerkraut dies mag ich
nämlich gern tut uns unendlich
schön wie die show recht gelb wie er
wunderbar gut dass gott sei dank
14 70 macht damit
das ist jetzt lustig ich habe mein
geldbeutel vergessen ach das ist jetzt
blöd das machen wir jetzt machen es
einfach so legen sie ist alles wieder
zurück und ich komme am morgen
nachmittag bei
[Applaus]